wir sind jetzt hier noch bei unserem
kumpel und netzwerk mitarbeiter elia und
es ist einfach mega cool wir haben viel
spaß weil wir können ja auf dem dach
chillen und der ausblick ist viel zu
groß für die für dieses leben ein paar
heute bietet exakt zwei frisch geduscht
neueste seines stupid der beuys klinik
weiter ja es wird es erwähnt ein cooler
tag mit dem ganzen live-auftritt sowas
wird sehr viel film wieder heute und los
geht's
so leute sind jetzt am set und gleich
gehts in die videotext diese bühne ist
irgendwie mittendrin und deshalb müsse
jetzt durchschlagen
und ja ich bin sehr gespannt
dr
denkbar sei
nach dem ball
wir sind auf der toilette und wird
komplett in belagert und unsere can auf
die eine oder andere das wirklich
lustiger wir durch die große halle
beides scheint leute werden es geschafft
wir sind hier um revier lebt auch noch
die musik würde kaum kopfzerbrechen
so leute es ging nicht mal alle leute
auf die bühne und ich bin hier mit
vielen leuten
hallo leute nehmen und es wird cool weil
habe ich ganz viele youtube in einem
video und es bedeutet sehr cool auf
jeden fall da kann ich dann schreibe ich
einfach die größte party mit auf der
wünschen sie täterin werden
die kinder
nicht richtig
sg
viel los
hey
das war's dann wohl von dem video die
aufdrucke wasser die aufdrucke
so leute wir sind jetzt hier noch bei
unserem kumpel und netzwerk mitarbeiter
elia und es ist einfach mega cool wäre
voll spaß weil wir können ja auf dem
dach und der ausblick ist viel zu groß
für die für dieses leben einfach und
entspannt auf jeden fall und gleichsam
fußballs freundin macht noch waffeln und
das ist auf jeden fall echt richtig
entspannt und also ich genieße das
gerade richtig ist mehr stellen wir
haben jetzt gerade hier eine ganze weile
gezählt ist es draußen auch schon dunkel
mittlerweile übrigens auf den
fernsehturm und so war es mir immer dass
sie trotz der reflexion und ja es war
auf jeden fall ganz entspannt hier und
jetzt gehen wir was essen
merkt einfach dass sie überhaupt keine
praxis habe in der liebe
ich habe angefangen zu essen bevor ich
euch gezeigt habe
da sind wir jetzt auf und es ist
ziemlich voll und sieht auf jeden fall
ganz entspannt aus
der komplette ungewohnte szenario bei
den letzten jahren beim alles schrie
was ist kunst wird ein cooler abend auf
jeden fall
ja hier bin ich jetzt dann auch zu hause
angekommen ihr habt jetzt als letztes
ein paar sequenzen wie sie irgendwo
sonst was wurde
wir haben schon vier und 18 ich stand
gerade noch vor der haustür
lonza gäste ja was heißt muss er hat den
schlüssel von ihnen stecken lassen und
wie muss wir mussten eigentlich besser
gesagt eine halbe stunde klingt und sind
jetzt auch endlich reingekommen bin
ziemlich müde es war noch mal richtig
coole abend und guter abschluss für ein
heftiges wochenende macht auf jeden fall
bock auf mehr
mehr einfach mit den mit den leuten
stellen weil die einfach nicht drauf
sind und so was ja okay ich fast ein
bisschen größer also macht's gut leute
und bis zum nächsten mal